hey David whatever happened to Donald
Trump's wall and does it matter for 2020
so all you need to know is that Trump is
claiming he did it
Trump is claiming he did it now you
might remember when he was running
Trump's promise was by the end of my
first term we'll have a wall across the
entire us-mexico border
um that was never going to happen Trump
also said Mexico would pay for it that
was never going to happen and none of it
has happened Trump has been able to
finagle getting about looks like a
hundred and fifty a hundred and sixty
miles of wall starting to be built some
of which will be completed by November
but what you need to understand is
despite that obviously being a failure
by Donald Trump to do what he promised
to do he's going to claim victory and a
lot of his followers are going to fall
for it so first of all there will be
very little fact-checking of Trump about
you promised the wall across the entire
border what the hell happened if it
happens Trump will say listen Democrats
got in the way coronavirus got in the
way and I built what I was able to do if
it weren't for Democrats I would have
built the whole thing but we've had a
huge success we have a hundred and fifty
miles bill or whatever and I did
everything I could and it is a victory
we have more miles now than we ever had
before you all get it right so he's
going to claim victory no matter what
and that is all that matters optics is
all that matters it is
this bizarre sort of like Rorschach test
of a wedge issue I had people calling me
on live calls a year and a half ago two
years ago there's this crazy a
Republican caller Doug who sometimes
calls and he's from Southern California
and he was saying the wall the wall the
wall the wall and I said well if Trump
doesn't build the wall during his first
term will you still vote for him for
reelection and he basically said
probably which means that it doesn't
really matter if he builds the wall even
just claiming to have succeeded despite
the oppression of Democrats on the wall
most trumpets are going to vote for him
anyway because they see Biden as worse
it's an incoherent explanation that
coronavirus and Democrats
did him from from building it
Republicans have also gotten the way of
giving him the funding that he wants
we've talked about all of that but the
2020 election is going to be primarily a
referendum on the state of the economy
at the time and what that means about
Trump's management of the country of
course it'll be affected by coronavirus
but Trump's actual handling of the virus
itself is mostly baked in already it
will be a matter of do we have a sort of
ebb between the waves that helps Trump
in November or not I don't believe that
the wall is going to be a factor in any
way people who are against the wall are
probably already not voting for Trump
people who are who voted for Trump in
2016 and hear him say we did it I made
150 miles and will do more my second
term they're gonna fall for it I do not
believe it's going to make a difference
if you disagree with me I of course want
to hear from you